I don't think I'm overstating him when I
say that the last two seasons of anime
were some of the best we've seen in
years
so spring 2019 has a lot to live up to
so what could possibly be carrying the
season well looking at the chart it
should be pretty obvious I mean because
this season we have the one the only
Mira tights it's a show about girls
wearing wet tights it's a show about
girls wearing wet myself one hand I
somehow find myself watching the second
anime suppository seen in back-to-back
seasons of some guy trying to get with
his teacher in that's the best part the
anime and on the other on debating
whether it's worth turning this off and
treasuring the small bit of dignity
I still have wretch shut up shop this is
the best part this is the best part this
is later show in animes new genre I
can't believe it's not hentai and I mean
I can't be the only one noticing
nowadays how the line between anime
plots and hentai plots is slowly
blurring at this point you can basically
see you or a hentai tags you can add to
an anime so why the hell not let's see
how many tags we can collect this season
and see how hentai anime has gotten I
swear to god out of me you better not do
it I don't need this [ __ ] in my anime
right now nobody asked to see some ugly
sweaty ogres bang a bunch of innocent
lollies being heap doing it anyway don't
do it don't [ __ ] do it if I see one
more big fat [ __ ] jungus when I leave
don't do it oh my god he's beautiful I
have the biggest nostalgia boner right
now it's like an erection Strayed in my
childhood
you crying I'm not crying these are just
the pre-cum of my soul man what time
period are we living in right now it
feels weird that it's 2019 and one of
the biggest shows this season is fruits
baskets but in this age of new season
announcements and remakes let it sink in
that your favorite order anime is
probably more likely to get another
season or remake now than it did when it
aired like a decade ago so that's right
boys the dream isn't dead yet you know
what I actually wanted to give a quick
shout out to China because I saw this
clip the other day and the Chinese made
anime and this is by far the best cg
crowds I've seen I didn't even notice it
was ceg until someone pointed it out and
if you really concentrate it does look a
bit stiff it's not perfect but dear Lord
we're finally making strides I thought
we were making progress I thought we
were making progress
hey it's a show called demon slayer
about a guy who slays demons and would
you look at that it's been an entire
episode of no one's been violently
assaulted so don't have to add any more
suspect tags but of God say you folks
more have done it again and I was sold
seeing this absolutely gorgeous
beautifully directed dynamic little
sister on a serious note though is cool
to see another shounen jump title
getting the premium treatment from you
photo at this time and once again I mean
it's you photo it looks like the action
scenes are exhilarating integrating the
trademark ufotable CG and dynamic camera
and I'm just happy to hear Yuki Kaji are
all of them again even if it sounds
eerily similar to her work on fate/zero
and Kara no Kyoukai and that's not a
complaint I swear cuz I say the same
thing about Sour no but come on it's
sour no everything's better with a sour
no drop it feels like ages since we last
heard him so you know what to prove my
point about sour no drops here's a
dramatic slow zoom of a waffle falling
over to the sound of the ape Titan theme
there he gone more like barely gone for
my memory no seriously this show was so
painful he forgets why I really don't
have much to say about it oh I've seen
enough anime to know where this is going
haha checkmate officer you can't arrest
me if I'm already arrested look let's be
honest when you see a character design
like this paired with the words 800 year
old fox girl your first reaction is
probably to think something dodgy is up
and hope to god that is not your penis
but dear Lord the helpful Fox sang
cosine is just one wholesome ass show
watching an episode of this is like the
real-life equivalent of eating a sense
of being you're just watching a
stressed-out overworked salary man being
pampered by a fox lolly and it's the
closest to real life HP recovery you're
gonna get this is like fanservice for
the Soul I mean just having a chasm hey
I heard you liked Issei KY so it took an
e say Chi and he say Chi nice a kind and
E say Chi then II sake I ve say kind to
another
Issei Chi is this ISA kind enough for
you I really didn't think I'd like this
as much as I do
I lied I like this exactly as much as I
thought I would but didn't want to admit
to myself I mean it's just a glorified
Eastlake I fanfiction who would have
thought that seeing Eastlake I character
x'b and with each other could be so damn
enjoyable cause you got all your
favorite characters here Kazuma ein
summer hot qua Amelia
C brew whoever this is truckin oh there
he is
there's my boy again of course the
season wouldn't be complete without at
least one new ISA Kai and I've got to
give it to Kendra in the margo sea while
most sa car nowadays strive to have at
least one original hook or premise
before diving to every other generic sa
[ __ ] engine imago is completely original
in its complete unoriginal 'ti you may
be thinking how it's possible to make a
generic anime that is more generic than
the most generic ISA Kai there is you
add a magic harem high school into it
yeah it's an e sake high magic harem
high school that's right people we have
reached new heights of generic Ness
what look let's be honest though if you
lease a high-power fantasy trash like me
you're gonna find yourself watching it
anyway for reasons you don't know why
because from the premise to the studio
to the staff members there is absolutely
nothing noteworthy about this shut era
manga sensei and domestic girlfriend
it can't be I found him my god I didn't
think he was real he's learned the
forbidden technique it's the man who's
mastered ultra incest on today's episode
of my social anxiety can't be this cute
we have hitori Bochy detailing the
adventures of a precious 14 year old
girl as she awkwardly stumbles through
making some tour my dad geez aka it's
basically just what ammo II honestly
though this is just [ __ ] adorable
with so many hashtag mood hashtag
relatable moments it's almost as if this
show is actually about if I was
reincarnated as a socially awkward
middle school anime girl though that
just makes it sound like a nice acai or
something all right what do we go next
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gay now where do I even start with
this one what tags this is even belong
to so welcome to the latest drug-induced
brain fart of Kunihiko Ichi Hara whose
works include the likes of Mara Roux
penguindrum and revolutionary girl utena
which if you're familiar with will give
you a much better sense of what you're
getting into than anything I could save
right now I don't think it's actually
possible to sum up this anime in the
single sentence but I'm gonna damn well
try anyway
imagine if Monica tree and URI and ice
had a persona flavored frog baby that
was anally conceived in Bollywood you're
watching three boys get transforms two
frogs or cappers when they get eaten
asked first by another Kappa as they end
people's anuses in order to consume
their inner desire they kinda like the
phantom thieves except instead of
inducing a change of heart they just eat
ass it's about eating ass
yes someone's finally made an anime
about eating the Kumar's work as famous
being very out there on a surface level
requiring you to dig through as many
layers to come to your own conclusion
which this definitely is buzz current
the appeal of it I mean you look at
something like this and maybe you see a
message about hidden desires it's
brought to the lens of traditional
Japanese folklore with the side of
homoeroticism set in the technologically
red lights modern day or you might just
see Avengers endgame spoilers I would
say Oh enjoyed it
but that would imply my brain had
rationalized the experience to something
close enough to resembling a coherent
thought
I know powerfully through yakuman what's
your winger EEMA
okay oh boy he knew I was coming one
punch man is back with a new studio new
staff members and a production schedule
that seems to have set itself on fire
all the signs were pointing to this
being an absolute tragedy so was it the
biggest disaster to ever grace our anime
community nah it was um it was okay
honestly this probably was the most okay
return I've seen it's really not as bad
as people are making it out to be but
when you're coming off one of the
greatest showcase of action animation in
the last decade to some of the most
bog-standard averaged fight scenes you
can find anywhere else yeah it's gonna
be a bit of a disappointment but it has
best girl yes this is canon best girl
there is no debate this time so I'll
still probably watch it anyway cause
animation aside the new character
designs don't even bother me that much
even if they've given saitama's bald
head this weird shiny gradient blush
thing which I've know I've seen in anime
before but I can't quite put my finger
on it wait a minute yes yes yes yes yes
do you that it's a familiar sound war is
coming
another long romantic comedy with one
male lead another show with many girls
worth protecting so pick your side
soldier there'll be a long and arduous
battle and whoever wins you won't be
forgetting it any time soon because
remember soldiers wars may come and go
but salt remains eternal I've picked my
corner all right I'm just gonna set up
camp here on Team sensei cuz I think
between this domestic girlfriend and the
previous teacher show I am ready to
declare that we have entered the dawn of
a new age the era of the Emoto is dead
it's time to start the age of the tills
that's right teachers I'd like to feed
all my love and attention to you because
teachers are hardworking humans just
trying to harness and is it wrong to
just want to sensei you can smile with
the pure happiness she deserves okay you
got it yeah yeah I think I got it all
right just follow
my lead okay today is gonna be the day
that I never throw it back sometimes all
it takes is one episode I went to
Carroll and chooses there with quite a
lot of hype as someone who really loves
anime about music and this being the
latest outing of bones and Shinichiro
Watanabe who if he didn't know is the
director behind shows like Cowboy Bebop
samurai Champloo zankyou no terror
us-based bandy kids on the slope so yeah
basically a nobody
even with that hype this first episode
floored me aside from the stunning
visuals it did pretty much everything a
first episode needed to do it takes
similar beats of some of the great music
anime of the past like Beck and Nana
you've got a completely original and
interesting setting in Mars of all
places in a future where culture is
produced by AI and to top it off you've
got this one scene where the two girls
are trying to figure out this song and
there's this beautiful little moment
when they're just fumbling around out of
sync jamming together for the first time
before slowly piecing it together and
then there's a moment where it just
clicks and I just felt this chill run
down my spine
[Music]
that's all it took for me to fall in
love with this show it could go to [ __ ]
but I am already invested my only regret
is that is behind Netflix license jail
meaning not many people are talking
about it but I'm probably gonna wait for
the full release after this anyway
because this is a show that I'm gonna
need to marathon so aside from that it's
[ __ ] great and absolutely nothing can
possibly go hey guys hope you enjoyed
the video thank you very much they too
careless just wean us Walt o supreme
sayin Nicolas Tatum sisters one zero
zero eight six grant fields and everyone
else my patreon to helping support me
for this month and making this video
possible
you know itself like talking about
anything else I wanted to give an extra
thanks to them today because if you
didn't know a few days ago my entire
channels just suddenly got demonetised
by YouTube which was yeah bit of a scare
luckily first you or I managed to get it
back pretty quickly but it was kind of a
wake-up call and made me really thankful
that I do have this safety net in case
unli something like this happens again
and I mean yeah I guess it goes to show
that it could really happen to anyone no
matter how big or small you are in this
anime community anyway though that's it
for me
I've been geared up and I'll see you all
next time